alors sur les annonces du fait qu'il y
aura en fait la gratuité de toutes les
appareils auditifs des lunettes
voilà des soins aussi dentaire je trouve
que c'est voilà c'est une très bonne une
très bonne chose
après sur les autres sans discours mois
après vous avez sur les ce sujet il a
dit que tu vas y avoir des lois mais il
n'y a pas beaucoup plus d' avance donc
sur le zéro comme prévu c'est une bonne
chose voire rien anciennement on va on
va revenir en détail sur ce discours
mais on attendait on parler d'un
tournant social à propos de ce discours
est ce que vous avez vu une inflexion
sociale de la politique du président de
la république
non je n'ai pas vu d'annoncés fortes je
n'ai pas vu un tournant social
il y a les annonces de future loi pour
2019 sur la dépendance sur l'hôpital ce
qui est intéressant c'est les mesures de
prévention tout particulièrement pour
les jeunes sur la question des troubles
auditifs ou pour les contrôles des
enfants pour la vue mais après il n'y a
pas vraiment de devrait annoncer il n'y
a pas une mesure forte qui va permettre
de réduire les inégalités
philippe palat oui donc pas de conquêtes
sociales essentielles comme annoncé non
il n'ya pas de conquête il n'y a pas
d'avancée il n'y a pas de réduction des
inégalités
il y a la confirmation de la gratuité
des lunettes et six de suite ce qui est
une bonne mesure
est ce que vous craignez pardon est ce
que vous craignez une hausse des
mutuelles du coup mais je pense que
c'est un sujet qu'il faut vraiment
travailler après avoir fait une annonce
il ne faut pas que cela soit financée
elle directement par des hausses de
tarifs
donc il faut y travailler ici à muret de
la ville de sarcelles il ya de
nombreuses propositions de la part de
les mutuelles
il est utile financement de cette mesure
je serai vigilante oui je serai
vigilante parce qu'il faut ne pas se
limiter à des belles annonces de
communication d être dans le réel
alors le président de la république a
aussi durant ce discours un défendu sa
réforme des retraites qui sera la
prochaine grande réforme du quinquennat
une réforme systémique ou un euro cotisé
ou les mêmes droits pour tous est ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne réforme alors
efforts de là pour l'instant on ne sait
pas exactement à quoi cela va
correspondre
moi je pense qu'on doit évoluer dans un
monde mais on ne peut pas rester assis
figé moi mon action à la région c'est
faire d'anticiper les mutations c'est
d'être la région de l'innovation et donc
au niveau du pays
il faut également être dans l'évolution
mais il faut rester quand même sur une
solidarité nationale qui doit être est
quand même très importante les principes
qui ont été émis à l'issue de la
libération avec le conseil national de
la résistance d'avoir une vraie
communauté française qui s'occupe de
ceux qui ont eu moins de chance ou plus
d'accidents de la vie et qu'il y ait une
solidarité entre les jeunes générations
les actifs et les retraités c'est
important donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment préserver ses acquis sociaux
d'avoir en fait une seule communauté
qu'il n'y ait pas de fractions entre
ceux qui ont des moyens de pouvoir
cotiser avec des assurances
complémentaires pour avoir des retraites
confortables et d'autres qui auraient
des minima très faible pile poil à la
veille de son discours à l'elysée à
l'elysée une formule choc pognon de
dingue ça ça vous a choqué mais moi je
pense à ceux qui bénéficient
de ces allocations de solidarité et je
pense qu'ils se sont sentis méprisés
parce que de toucher le rsa d'être au
chômage de toucher des allocations
chômage
c'est sais pas je veux dire devant le
palais leur argent et d'entendre que
c'est un pognon de dingue je pense
qu'ils ont vraiment d'un sentiment
d'humiliation mais c'est dommage c'est
dommage je suis lancé je trouve c'est
gratuit et c'est ce n'est pas un
discours qui rassembleur pour la france
et la france elle a besoin d'être
ensemble quand même